[Music]
well we all want to save money and there
are hundreds of apps out there that can
help kirsten joyce
in studio with on your side great ways
to make your money go a bit further
and do a little clearing out at the same
time well brian want to jump start your
holiday savings or save for vacation
selling your old items can help with
that you don't have to be an expert at
sales to make money this way
tara clarkson is a respiratory therapist
and a busy single mom of two with growth
spurts this henderson mother is
constantly changing up clothes and
athletic shoes brand new cleats i mean
literally they worn them twice before
covid
for her seven-year-old son and
nine-year-old daughter the turnover time
is incredible
she found a method to save time and
money using a number of different apps
like offer up and let go which combined
marketplaces over the summer
henderson swap and shop and for only
brand name items henderson hire and yard
sale you don't have to go to
the store and pay top dollar for these
things she bought this huge printer from
a woman on let go for 50 bucks
she'll go online when she's in need of
something ooh an ikea desk for 140 bucks
and while browsing she's also got her
own stockpile of items ready to list
and sell they're completely friendly you
pop a picture on there
what you're selling the details and you
go from there
these are rollerblades for probably like
a two three-year-old maybe four-year-old
they are brand
new kids grow out of shoes clothes and
toys so quickly
imaginex right here for a little boy
these apps let her clear house of these
gently used items
and with the holidays just around the
corner she'll be able to cash in on what
she sells to put right back into
additional purchases
save for christmas time the kids only
wear snow outfits for this amount of
time and you're going oh my gosh
that snow bunny outfit's too small i'm
going to go on there and look for
gloves now to be on the safe side you
can always have a seller or buyer meet
you in a public place a coffee shop
police substation or parking lot if you
don't want them pulling up to your home
there's also of course craigslist and
facebook marketplace and for all the
apps that we told you about in henderson
they're pretty much the same for your
neighborhood you just have to look
whichever part of town you live in